[موسيقى]
بيتك بيتك ابقى حيث انت هذا ما فرضه تفشي
وباء كورونا انخفض عدد السياح عالميا
بنسبه
56% خلال الشهور الخمسه الاولى فقط من هذا
العالم من هذا العام يواجه قطاع السفر
والسياحه اسوا ازماته هذا هو اذا الواقع
الذي فرضه كورونا على مئات الملايين في
انحاء العالم توقفت الطائرات واغلقت
المطارات والغيت ملايين الحجوزات الفندقيه
وبدت مقاصد سياحيه عديده ومدن العالم
الكبرى مهجوره من جراء اجراءات الاغلاق
التي فرضت اثرى هذا الاغلاق تجاوزت خسائر
السياحه العالميه 300 مليار دولار في
الشهور الخمسه الاولى من هذا العام وبات
شبح البطاله يهدد اكثر من 120 مليونا من
العاملين في هذا هذا القطاع وخسرت شركات
الطيران العالميه نحو 85 مليار دولار
والتوقعات المستقبليه اشد قتامه اذا واجه
العالم موجه ثانيه من تفشي وباء كورونا
عربيا قدرت خسائر قطاع السياحه منذ بدايه
تفشي كورونا ب 130 مليار دولار وهذا يترجم
في تراجع مساهمه السياحه والسفر في الناتج
المحلي الاجمالي بالعالم العربي باكثر من
50% فمتى تعود حركه السفر والسياحه الى
طبيعتها ليس سريعا يرد خبراء ومؤسسات
دوليه فالامر يتطلب فتره تعاف تتراوح بين
ثلاث وخمس سنوات فهل فقد البشر عربيا
وعالميا رغبتهم في السفر والسياحه وما
التغييرات التي ستفرض نفسها على قطاع
السفر والسياحه لتتواءم مع استمرار ازمه
كورونا وهل تعوض السياحه الداخليه قدرا من
خسائر السياحه العالميه وما امكانيه
القيام بجهد دولي جماعي لدعم هذا القطاع
والعاملين فيه سنشاهد قصه السياحه رهينه
كورونا ونستكمل بقيتها مع يفينا الدكتور
حسن الزواوي الاستاذ الباحث في الشؤون
الاقتصاديه وسايمون كالدر الخبير في شؤون
السفر والسياحه لكن ما رايكم الان
مشاهدينا ان نتابع قصه السياحه رهينه
كورونا
من اوروبا الى افريقيا مرورا باسيا
والامريكتين وجهات سياحيه تاثرت بفيروس
كوفي 19 فالغ ملايين الحجوزات وتوقفت
شركات الطيران واغلقت الفنادق ابوابها
وبات القطاع السياحي والقطاعات المرتبطه
به قاب قوسين او ادنى من
[موسيقى]
الانهيار قبل ظهور فيروس كوفي 19
كانت الحياه في كثير من الدول طبيعيه فساح
الشهيره تعج بالسياح والمتاحف تستقبل
زائريها والمطارات
مزدحمه لكن بعد ظهور الفيروس اختبات المدن
خلف جدران الخوف ودخلت في عزله الزاميه
فانخفضت صناعه السياحه والضيافه حول
العالم الى ادنى مستوياتها ما شكل انتكاسه
في اقتصادات معظم دول
العالم
اللي ما حبت مصاري راح حط بضاعه ليش يعني
انا بدي خاش على موسم قوي فنحنا تفاجانا
يوم وليله ب حضرنا موسم بيوم وليله سكرنا
قعدنا
بالدور احنا قت يوم بيوم اولادنا بطلنا
نقدر ناويهم بطلنا نقدر نامن لهم قوه
يومهم البسيط
جدا هذا هو حال القطاع السياحي في الاردن
بعدما خلت المدن الاردنيه والفنادق
والساحات الداخليه من السياح فعظ مدينه
بترا الورديه توارت خلف جدران الخوف
والمدرج الروماني في جرش هجره السياح فيما
الحركه في البحر الميت في ادنى
مستوياتها في الواقع السياحه
من اهم اعمده الاقتصاد في الاردن بتساهم ب
14% من الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي مساهمه السياحه في الناتج المحلي
للعام 2019 كانت 4.2 مليار دينار ولكن هلا
من شهر ثلاثه وطالع لليوم الحركه السياحيه
صفر في الوقت الذي خفتت فيه اضواء الفنادق
والمقاهي والمتاحف والقوارب التي كانت
تمتلئ بالسياح كانت الحركه في اقسام
الطوارئ تسجل اعلى مستوياتها بعد ما احكم
روس كوفي 19 قبضته على
[موسيقى]
العالم في اشهر الصيف كنا نعمل تقريبا من
25 الى 26 يوما في
الشهر وبعد الجائحه انتقلنا من هذه الحياه
النشطه الى حياه فارغه
تماما لقد تاثرنا جميعا بشكل سلبي للغايه
فنحن لم نقم باغلاق مكاتبنا فحسب انما
اغلقنا ابواب منازلنا
ايضا كما في كل الدول ارخت جائحه كورونا
بظلالها على الاقتصاد التركي وكبدته خسائر
مليارات الدولارات فمن القطاع السياحي
وحده حصلت تركيا في العام
2019 على مدخول من العمله الصعبه قدر
بحوالي 34 مليارا ونصف المليار دولار بحسب
بيانات المعهد الاحصائي في تركيا لكن
استمرار ضائقه كورونا يزيد من صعوبه
التعويض لكون تركيا بلدا سياحيا
بامتياز والناس اصلا حتت توجه ل يعني
لسياحه فرديه يعني ما ما ما عاد انه الناس
تشتغل على موضوع الجروب
والشغل الضخم انت او انا او هو اي واحد
حفض من يوم طالع انه يسافر من خلال جروب
حيسافر
لوحده الناس او السائح حيصير يفتش على
الفنادق الصغيره على الفنادق البوتيك فكل
شي راح
يختلف في هذه الفتره لجا بعض زملائنا الى
القيام باعمال مختلفه كمترجمين للغه
الانجليزيه عبر الانترنت او كمدرسين للغات
الاجنبيه فيما اخرون بداوا يعملون في
التجاره ومنهم من اضطر للعوده الى مسقط
راسهم ومتابعه حياتهم الاجتماعيه مع اسرهم
والتوجه للعمل بالزراعه كي يستطيعوا تامين
لقمه العيش لهم
ولعائلاتهم بحسب تقرير صادر عن منظمه
السياحه العالميه في شهر ايار مايو من
العام 2020 فمن المتوقع ان تصل خسائر سوق
السياحه العالميه في العام 2020 الى حوالي
ترليون و2 مليار دولار وينخفض عدد السياح
الدوليين الى ما بين 850 مليونا ومليار
ووم مليون سائح فيما يهدد شبح البطاله 120
مليون عامل في قطاع السياحه
[موسيقى]
العالمي
كل شيء توقف بعدما تبلغنا بضروره الاغلاق
الالزامي وطرنا لالغاء جميع الامسيات
وحفلات الزفاف المخطط
لها والحفلات الخاصه بالشركات والحفلات
الموسيقيه
من الصعب في الوقت الراهن اعطاء ارقام
محدده عن حجم الخسائر في ظل هذه التقلبات
ولكننا نشهد عوده الاعمال ولو ببطء الا
انه عندما اضطررنا للاقفال التام كان من
السهل اعطاء ارقام عن الخسائر فالخسائر
كانت بنسبه
100% من حجم الاعمال واليوم بعد ان استانف
العمل نحن عند حدود
من حجم
اعمالنا من المبكر جدا ان نعرف وطاه تاثير
الفيروس من الناحيه الاقتصاديه ولكن
يمكننا ان نقول انه بعد مضي عده اشهر من
توقفنا عن العمل هناك انخفاض بلغ 70 في
بنسبه الحجوزات مقارنه مع العام الماضي
ويبقى الامل لدينا في اقبال الزبائن في
اللحظه
الاخيره اعلنت هيئه الاحصاء الرسميه
الاقتصاد الفرنسي يعمل بثلث طاقته مقارنه
بمستوياته الطبيعيه نتيجه لتفشي يرس
كورونا ويعد قطاع السياحه واحدا من اكثر
القطاعات تضررا فبعد ان كان القطاع
السياحي يساهم بنحو 10 في من الناتج
المحلي الاجمالي بات اليوم يشكل واح وث
بالعش في فقط بحسب هيئه الاحصاء الرسميه
الفرنسيه يعد صيف باريس فتره مهمه من حيث
السياحه من ناحيه الانشطه الترفيهيه فيما
تحتل سياحه الاعمال وحدها نحو 50 في من
النشاطات الا انها غير متيه هذا الصيف لقد
كان تاثير الفيروس واضحا للغايه في فرنسا
باكملها وخاصه في باريس وقد لمسنا غياب
السياحه بشكل كامل اليوم يعاني القطاع
السياحي في باريس بشده بسبب توقف النشاط
لعده اشهر خاصه وان عددا من المؤسسات لا
تزال
مغلقه
الان وبعد استئناف العمل والتمكن من
استقبال الزبائن هناك بالفعل بعض القيود
اذ يمكننا فقط استقبال الزبائن في
المساحات المكشوفه مع احترام التعليمات
الصحيه في حين لا يزال من شبه المستحيل
استقبالهم داخل المركب فكل ما كان يحدث من
حفلات وسهرات راقصه وما الى ذلك في الطبق
السفلي لا يمكننا استئنافه في الوقت
الحالي
[موسيقى]
كنا في حاله اصبحنا في حاله قاسيه جدا ما
نجمش مع تبقى نهار كامل معناه باللي تبقى
ما تبيعش ما تخدم ماثم ح
شي
جات الكورونا هذه معناها تحطيم كامل ما
تشوفوا مع في السوق معنا فارغ ما ثماش
معناها كونتاكت معناها بين العباد في
بعضها ما ثماش معناها الحريف الحريف تفقد
جمله وتفصيلا انا هذ ظروف قاسيه نمر بها
لابعد جتنا سابقا صارت ظروف سابقا كذلك
ماهيش بصفه هذ الصفه اع العفان وعفاكم
الله الوباء تع الكورونا هذا معناها حطمها
معناها التجاره بصفه
عامه يشكل القطاع السياحي في تونس واحدا
من اهم روافد الناتج الاجمالي المحلي بما
نسبته 7% بحسب المعهد الوطني للاحصاء لكن
وبسبب تاثير فيروس كوفي 19 شهدت العائدات
السياحيه تراجعا حادا بلغ
51% مقارنه مع العام الماضي اي بتراجع
مليار و1
مليون و300 الف دينار تونسي بحسب المؤشرات
الماليه الصادره عن البنك المركزي التونسي
بتاريخ العاشر من يوليو تموز 2020 قطاع
السياحه تقريبا في حدود 9 مليار دينار
تونسي هي العائدات الكليه للقطاع السياح
القطاع هذا الذروه اعه هي شهر س وشهر 8
وشهر ت وع توقف النشاط يؤدي الى خساره
تقريبا 6 مليار دينار
تونسي احنا في في 2019 عملنا اكثر من 9
مليون سائح وكانت هذه مع ارقام خارقه
للعاده وصلنا لها بعد ثلاث او اربع سنوات
من تعب في الترويج وفي تركيز على برشا
اسواق توا برشا موظفين خسروا وظائفهم
تاثير كان في مشكله في حتى في الموسمين
العمل الموسمين فما برشا مش يرجعوا يخدموا
في الاوتيلات بعهم ف اوتيلات التوا مازالت
[موسيقى]
مسكره لليوم
السعه هذم حتى اي تغيير مع في الخدمه هي
هي احنا نتعامل كنا توريستيك نتعامل مع
التوريست الاجان بصفه عامه
ماماش ماماش سائح معناها من اي معناها
خاصه الدول الاوروبيه مع ماماش لا من
الدول العربيه ولا الاوروبيه ماماش الظروف
هي قاسيه جدا بل زادت
قساوه بعد تفشي فيروس كوفي 19
اغلاق المطارات تعرض قطاع الطيران
والقطاعات المرتبطه به الى ضربه قاسيه ادت
الى خسائر فادحه في القطاع لم نتوقع انه
توصل الازمه للمستويات اللي وصلت لها
حاليا حاليا يعني تم اغلاق العالم كله فه
الازمه كان لها تاثير كثير كبير على قطاع
الطيران وتاثير كثير على شركات الطيران
شركات الطيران الان يعني تحارب من اجل
البقاء في حال استمرت فرض القيود على
السفر لمده ثلاثه اشهر دراسات الايات تشير
الى انه هنالك 25 مليون وظيفه عالميا
معرضه للخطر هذا بضم صناعه الطيران وبضم
القطاعات الاخرى ايضا بحسب موقع الاتحاد
الدولي للنقل الجوي ايات بلغت خسائر شركات
الطيران حول العالم حتى اواخر شهر يوليو
تموز 2020 4 مليار و300 مليون دولار في
حين تم الغاء ما يقارب 7 ملايين و500 ال
رحله وانخفض الطلب على الرحلات
54% ومن المتوقع ان ترتفع الخسائر لتبلغ
419 مليار دولار مع نهايه عام 2020 بالعام
الماضي حسب احصائيات ايات كان دخل شركات
الطيران يزيد عن 800 مليار دولار وحققت
ارباح تزيد عن 30 مليار دولار التوقع انه
في عام 2020 رح يهبط الدخل من 800 مليار
الى حوالي 419 مليار يعني هبوط 50% بدخل
شركات الطيران هذا ينتج عنه خسائر تزيد عن
844 مليار دولار لعام 2020 عمره ما كان
وصل هذا الرقم خسائر شركات الطيران في
العالم حتى لو اطلعنا على مؤشرات اخرى مثل
الاحتياطات النقديه لشركات الطيران فشركات
الطيران في المنطقه
عننا الاحتياطات تبلغ من من شهرين الثلاثه
اشهر هذا بيعني انه شركات الطيران فعليا
تعاني من ازمه
سيوله في الوقت الذي يلملم فيه القطاع
السياحي خسائره ويستعد العالم لالتقاط
انفاسه تسعى الحكومات الى وضع خطط لانقاذ
ما تبقى من مواسمها السياحيه من خلال
بروتوكولات صحيه وتشجيع السياحه الداخليه
الا ان كلمه الفصل تبقى لفيروس كوفي 19
نحاول من خلال برنامج السياحه
المحليه تعويض جزء
يسير للقطاع اكيد لن يعوض الخساره الكبيره
انا اتحدث بان السياحه المحليه تشكل فقط
10% ربما من الحجم
الدخل
السياحي مع اعاده الفتح الجزئي نحن في
انتظار السياحه الداخليه فقط ونحن بحاجه
الى وقت لنعود الى حياتنا
الطبيعيه
[موسيقى]
نتوقع ان تتحسن الاوضاع مع بدايه الصيف في
العام المقبل نحن نعتقد ان هذا العام قد
انتهى وستكون بدايه الانفراج في شهر اذار
مارس ونيسان
[موسيقى]
ابريل في الوقت الذي يكافح فيه القطاع
السياحي للبقاء على قيد الحياه من خلال
العوده التدريجيه تطل تحضيرات جديه من
موجه ثانيه لكورونا اكثر فتكا من الموجه
الاولى لتصبح معها كل الخطط والحلول رهنه
في يد كوفي 19 ويدخل معها مستقبل السياحه
في مصير
مجهول السياحه رهينه كورونا يبدو ان
العالم اجمع بات رهينه لهذا الوباء وقان
الله منه ورفعه عنا عاجلا غير اجل نرحب
بكم مشاهدينا الكرام وبضيف بين الكريمين
من الرباط الدكتور حسن الزواوي الباحث في
الشؤون الاقتصاديه ومن لندن سايمن كالدر
الخبير في شؤون السفر والسياحه نبدا مع
السيد سايمن ونتساءل معك كيف رصد في
الواقع تاثير هذه الجائحه العالميه على
قطاعي السياحه والسفر مقارنه بازمات كبرى
عاشها العالم من
قبل لم ارى اي شيء مشابه لهذا الامر في
السابق انا كنت دائما اقدم تقارير حول
قطاع السياحه والسفر لما يقارب 40 سنه وفي
الوقت الذي عشنا فيه الكثير من الازمات
الاقتصاديه والمشاكل راينا سارز المتلازمه
التنفسيه الحاده الوخيمه وكذلك راينا
انفلونزا الطيور في 2005 و2006 وكذلك
شهدنا الانفلونزا الخنازير في 2009
بالاضافه الى الاقتصادي في نفس الوقت لكن
لا شيء مما مضى يقارن بالانهيار المشابه
الذي نشهده حاليا اذا في التقرير الجيد
الذي استمعنا اليه قبل قليل هناك ارقام لا
تصدق وامل ان اضع واحده من هذه الارقام في
منظور معين وهي تتعلق بخساره الاقتصادات
الكبيره التي تخسر
الف دولار في كل ثانيه اذا هذا يدمر فرص
العمل يدمر الامل يدمر جانبا كبيرا من
اقتصاد العالم اتحول اليك دكتور حسن اذا
كان هذا يدمر جانب كبير من الاقتصاد
العالمي الاقتصاد العربي هو جزء من خسائر
هذا ونصيب العالم العربي من هذه الخسائر
بلغ الى حد الان اكثر من 130 مليار دولار
كيف تتوزع من هم اكثر المتضررين خاصه من
الدول التي تعتمد على السياحه والسفر كاحد
اعمده
اقتصاداتها
ا شكرا جزيلا على الاستضافه الكريمه
الاختي الفضيله لمناقشه هذا الموضوع الذي
هو باهميه بمكان اعتقد بان بالنسبه لدول
شمال افريقيا او الشرق الاوسط هي دول في
غالبيتها تعتمد تعتبر فيها
السياحه دعامه اساسيه لاستراتيجيتها بحيث
ان اذا اخذنا رقم رقم بسيط من بين الدول
لان الاكثريه من الدول من هته الدول هي
دول سائره في طريق النمو من بين 42 42
دوله من الدول السائره في طريق النمو
تعتبر
السياحه دعامه لاقتصاديات
هذ والاساسي هو ان
كما سبق ان اشرتم في في التقرير هو ان هته
الازمه او ازمه كوفي 19 بدات في الصين وكل
والكل يعلم ان الصين تعتبر اكبر سوق
سياحيه في العالم اكبر سوق سياحيه في
العالم يعني ان جميع الدول التي تستقبل
السياحه الصينيين تاثروا بشكل
كبير من ناحيه تعريف السياحه هو قطاع حساس
جدا بحيث اي يعتمد على على الثقه والثقه
يمكن
زعزعتها
باعمال بسيطه ولكن كما اشار الخبير ان لم
يسبق للعالم ان شاهد الاثار السلبيه التي
نلمسها حاليا عاد السياح في العالم نزل
بشكل كبير حيث يقترب في بعض الاحيان الى
الى الى الى 80% بالنسبه لدول شمال
افريقيا او الشرق الاوسط اعتقد مثلا الذا
اخذنا نماذج فبالنسبه للمغرب فالقطاع
السياحه يمثل اكثر من 7% في الناتج
الداخلي الخام وبالنسبه لمصر مثلا تفوق
هذه النسبه 15% وبالتالي فان هذه هذه هذه
الدول ستعاني وسيصعب الرجوع الى الى ما
قبل الى ما ق قبل كوفيد بعض الارقام بعض
الارقام بالنسبه لهذه الدول مثلا بالنسبه
لعدد السياح في المغرب فقد نزل ب تقريبا
70% والعائدات من العمله الصعبه وهو قطاع
يعول عليه في هذا الاطار في المغرب وفي
العديد من الدول نزل ب 60%
بالنسبه لتونس التي
كانت التي كانت تراهن على هذه السنه يعني
سنه 2020 بعد الازمات التي عانتها منذ
2011 كانت تراهن على س مليون 7 مليون سائح
ولكن مع الاسف نفس الشيء بالنسبه لمصر
التي كانت تتوقع ان يصل عدد السياح في
2020 15 مليون ولكن ا الجميع الجميع تضرر
دكتور حسن دعني اعود مره اخرى لسيد سايمن
كالدر ونتساءل حقيقه عن الول الاكثر تضررا
من وجهه نظرك فيما يخص قطاعي السفر
والسياحه في العالم هل هي ضروره الدول
التي ربما صنفت
كالا اصابه بهذا الوباء ام ماذا كيف يتم
تصنيف الاكثر
تضررا اذا المعايير بالنسبه لي بالنسبه
للدول الاكثر تضررا هي تلك التي تعتمد
بشكل كبير جدا الدول التي تعتمد على
السياحه والدكتور حسن الذي تحدث قبل قليل
عن مصر
حيث ان السياحه تشكل تقريبا سدس العائد
الاقتصادي اذا هذا ستكون له اثاره الكبيره
على مصر وكذلك على دول اخرى في القاره
الافريقيه هناك الكثير من الاقتصادات
المعتمده على السياحه بشكل كبير جدا خصوصا
في شرق افريقيا كينيا تنزانيا وغيرها من
الدول هذه الدول التي تعتمد على
تدفقات تتعلق بافراد ء ياتون الى هذه
الدول من اجل خلق فرص العمل وكذلك من اجل
حمايه الحياه البريه هناك اثار كبيره على
الدول التي تعتمد على السياحه في جنوب شرق
اسيا في تايلاند وفي ماليزيا وكذلك في بعض
الدول الاخرى مثل الفيتنام اذا هناك
تابعات كثيره في مناطق مختلفه من العالم
في اي وجهه يكون فيها عدد كبير من السياح
واوروبا لانها تعتبر بشكل نسبي ثريه
مقارنه مع بقيه العالم كما راينا في
التقرير الذي عرضتم وه الكثير من المناطق
في باريس وكذلك في فرنسا هناك مناطق تتم
زيارتها من قبل السياح كلها كلها ينقصها
عدد كبير من السياح اذا كان لديهم حمله
نجحت بشكل نسبي والتي كانت تدعو الى
البقاء في فرنسا وهذا كان له اثاره ربما
للتعويض على بعض النقائص التي ترتبت عن
نقص السياحه نفس الشيء بالنسبه للندن
والتي تشهد عدد كبير من الزوار من الشرق
الاوسط من الصين من الامريكتين لندن هي
حاليا فارغه واهم الفنادق كذلك ليس بها
سياح هذا الشيء لم اشهد في السابق
وبالنسبه لكل ضيف غير موجود بامكانك ان
تتاكد هناك ك خسائر من حيث الوظائف الناس
يخسرون شريحه كبيره من مدخراتهم في الوقت
الذي يحاولون فيه الاستعداد او انتظار
حاله التعافي لكن المشكله لا احد يعرف متى
سياتي هذا التعافي ممتاز ما ذكرته فيما
يخص نقطه ان الناس اوحتى الحكومات بدات
تشجع الناس على نوع من السياحه المحليه
دكتور حسن المغرب له تجربه جيده في هذا
الموضوع حتى قبل كورونا يعني في المغرب
السياحه المحليه تصل عوائدها حسب وزاره
السياحه المغربيه الى اكثر من ثلاثه
مليارات دولار سنويا كيف تاثر هذا النمط
بازمه كورونا هل اقبل الناس اكثر واكثر
على السياحه المحليه داخل الحدود البلد ام
ماذا ما السلوك الذي لاحظته في المغرب
مثلا اعتقد بان حينما حينما تم اتخاذ
قرارين اساسيين في المغرب او في في العديد
من الدول الا وهما اولا القرار الاول هو
اغلاق الحدود الجويه والبحريه والقرار
الثاني هو الحجر الصحي اثر كب اثر كثيرا
على على هذا القطاع حتى بالنسبه للسياحه
الداخليه لان في البدايه كان حجر صحي كلي
وانما كما اشرت الاخت الفضيله فان السياحه
الداخليه فعلا تلعب دورا كبيرا في المغرب
بحيث ان الحكومه المتعاقبه قامت بمجموعه
من برامج التي يمكنها ان تشجع هذه هذه
السياحه ولكن رغم ذلك اعتقد بان هناك عمل
كبير ينتظرون في هذا الاطار بحيث ان اعتقد
بان يجب يجب اولا التربيه على ثقافه السفر
ثم من اجل من اجل تنميه السياحه الداخليه
ضروري من من من منتوج منتوج سياحي يلائم
سلوك وطبيعه الاسره المغربيه التي تكون في
غالب بال الاحيان ممتده
وا السياحه الداخليه ايضا
تستلزم وجود فنادق باثمان
[موسيقى]
باثمنة
ا وقع ما وقع حيث ان عدد
الاصابات كبر و بمناسبه وبخصوص
بمناسبه العدد العدد الكبير ديال التنقلات
ديال المواطنين المغاربه بمناسبه العيد
عيد الاضحى ادى الى لم تعطي لم تعطي هذه
السياحه الداخليه ما كان مرجوا منها بحيث
ان السلطات قامت بفتح عدد كبير من الشواطئ
عدد كبير من من من من الفنادق ولكن شريطه
احترام مجموعه من الاجراءات والبروتوكول
الصحي بحيث انه فرض على الجميع ان لا ان
لا
يفوق ان لا يفوت 50% من من من طاقه
الاستيعاب سواء بالنسبه للايواء او
بالنسبه للمطاعم تبقى طبعا اجراءات اتخذت
للتخفيف لكن دائما بقيود سيد سايمن يعني
بعض الدول في الواقع حاولت التحايل على
هذه الازمه غير المسبوقه كما وصفتها مثلا
في استراليا نيوزيلندا اتفقت على ما يسمى
بممر سفر او فقاعه سفر هذا الامر يسمح ان
صح التعبير بالانتقال الى اماكن محدده
هناك ترتيبات ايضا بين بعض الدول شاهدناها
في هذا الشان الاتحاد الاوروبي شهدنا ان
سياحتهم بقيت بينهم قبل ان يتم تشديد طبعا
هذه الامور في وقت لاحق عندما ارتفع عدد
الاجراءات السؤال هل هذه الاتفاقات
باعتقادك يمكن ان تكون حلا وتكون كافيه
لتشجيع حركه السفر
والسياحه اذا ربما قد نريد ان نفكر بهذا
الامر ربما في منطقه الشرق الاوسط وشمال
افريقيا ان تكون هناك تدابير وترتيبات
لابقاء الحدود مفتوحه لكن للاسف التجربه
في اوروبا تشي بان هذه المساله لن تكون
ناجعه هنا اتحدث ال من لندن حيث انه في
العاشر من يوليو السابق قمنا بفتح الكثير
من الوجهات الكثير من الدول قلنا انه
بامكاننا الذهاب الى كرواتيا اسبانيا
فرنسا سويسرا والاستمتاع
بالعطله وعندما تعودون فانكم لن تحتاجوا
الى الحجر المنزلي بمعنى ان يكون هناك حجر
ل 14 يوما لكن بشكل تدريجي راينا هذه
المساله بدات تتراجع ولو كنت لاذهب الى
شواطئ اسبانيا او الى مدن كرواتيا او الى
الضواحي مثلا او قرى فرنسا فانه للاسف
عندما اعود ساحتاج ان اكون في مرحله حجر
صحي اذا هناك بعض الدول التي نجحت في
ابقاء كورونا او اصابات الكورونا محدوده
من حيث الاصابات مثل لاتفيا وليتوانيا
وغيرها من الدول هذه الدول التي فرضت بعض
القيود على جنسيات اوروبيه اخرى للاسف كل
دوله جربت هذه المساله هي تتطلع لترى كيف
تبلي الدول الاخرى واذا ما راوا ان نسبه
الاصابات تصل الى مستويات مخيفه يقومون
بالاغلاق اذا هذه المساله تجعل الامر صعبا
بالنسبه لاي مسافر يود السفر في المستقبل
ليخط وفان
ثقه المستهلكين والسياح تتضاءل
لانه ليس هناك امكانيه ليقوموا بحجز
سفارتهم اذا لا احد يعرف في اوروبا متى
سيفتح او تفتح الولايات المتحده ابوابها
وهذه تعتبر كذلك مساله صعبه بالنسبه
للسلطات والهيئات السياحيه خطوط الطيران
وكذلك بالنسبه للفنادق
اذا التعويضات او ايجاد بدائل محليه هي
تكون مهمه بالنسبه للبريطانيين عندما نقول
لهم بامكانكم ان تقضوا اجازتكم في المملكه
المتحده ربما سيفكرون في الساحل او ربما
يفكرون في الضواحي او ما الى ذلك لن
يفكروا بالمدن لان هذه هي الماكن التي
ربما الزوار الاعتياديين يذهبون اليها
وبالتالي هذه المساله لا تكون ناجعه في
مستوى كبير جدا من حالاتها لا تكون ناجحه
على مستوى كبير من الحالات الدكتور حسن
سؤالي اليك ماذا عن المستوى العربي هل
باعتقادك مثل هذه الافكار يمكن ان تطرح
تجرب ويرى ان كانت يعني تنجح او او تفشل
هل هناك ربما استراتيجيه او تفكير جماعي
ان صح التعبير على المستوى العربي يعني في
موضوع مثلا هذه الفقاعه او حتى ممرات
السفر مثل ما فعل الاوروبيون راينا ذلك في
اكثر من دوله ومناطق اخرى من العالم
تحدثنا عن نيوزيلندا واستراليا
ايضا
اسمحي لي الاخت الفاضله نقول بان الازمه
او ازمه الصحيه او ازمه كوفيد هي ازمه
عالميه والغريب في الامر هو ان جميع الدول
تبحث عن الحلول الفرديه في الوقت الذي لا
انا اعتقد بان بدون تنسيق جماعي بدون
تنسيق دولي لا يمكن ان ان ان ان نتجاوز
هذه الازمه اما بالنسبه لنسبه نجاح او
امكانيه نجاح مثلها ممرات سفر
او فقع السياحيه اعتقد بان هي نوع من هو
نوع من الحجر الصحي اعتقد يمكن ان اعتبرها
حجر صحي من نوع اخر بحيث ان السائح اذا
اراد ان يسافر فهو يبحث عن الحريه هو يبحث
عن الراحه وحينما تقول لشخص انه يسافر
وحينما يرجع يجب ان يقوم ان يجلس 14 يوما
في
منزله من اجل
عدم انه لا يصيب احدا اخر بهذا المرض
فاعتقد بانه سيكون سيكون الهاجس الاكبر هو
الخوف وكلما كان الخوف كلما انخفضت الثقه
وكلما انخفضت الثقه يصعب يصعب السفر في ظل
استمرار الجائحه الخبراء يقولون بان هذه
الجائحه موجوده وهي باقيه
وسنتعامل حين ان نجد اللقاح تحذيرات الان
حتى ربما من موجه ثانيه للاسف من هذا
الوباء هل يعني ذلك بالضروره بان الناس
سيفقدون الثقه تماما في السفر و بالتالي
ان الناس لن يعني يفكروا في هذا الموضوع
يعني لن يبدو رغبه ان صح التعبير في هذا
الموضوع اعتقد بان من بين الحلول هناك
حلول ظرفيه وكل حكومه تحاول من من من حسب
بامكانيتها ان ان تقوم باجراءات التي يمكن
لها ان ان ان ان تنمي سياحتها الداخليه
ولكن اعتقد بان من اجل تنميه السياحه
الداخليه هناك شروط كما كما سلفت الذكر
هناك شروط اولها هي انه ان تكون ثقافه
السفر عند الساكنه وهته الثقافه غالبا ومع
الاسف في هته الدول في دولنا سواء في شمال
افريقيا او في الشرق الاوسط سفر هو ان
تذهب الى الخارج اما ان تذهب الى اوروبا
او تذهب الى الى الى امريكا في الوقت الذي
الذي ن توفروا فيه وبلداننا تتوفر على
مقومات مقومات
سياحيه عظيمه جدا اسمحيلي الاخت الفاضله
ان اقول لك بان النموذج في المغرب في بعض
الاحيان حينما اسافر الى الجنوب الشرقي
المغربي وحينما اقوم بتصوير مجموعه من
المناظر فالاخوان حينما ارجعوا الى الرباط
الاخوان يقولون هل هذه الصور من من
البرازيل من امريكا التي
هيقول انها مجتمعاتنا العربيه نتيجه
بالفعل لعدم وانعدام السياحه الداخليه
التي يمكن ان تكون رافدا حقيقيا بدليل ما
يحدث الان مع كل هذا الاغلاق المخاوف سيد
سايمن من استمرار هذه الازمه ازمه كورونا
باعتقادك كيف يمكن ان تنعكس على سلوكيات
الناس في السفر يعني الاوروبيون انتم الى
جز الى يعني وقت قريب كنتم جزء من هذا
الفضاء اعتادوا السفر في مجموعات هل هذا
النمط سيتغير بالضروره ام ماذا الى ماذا
ستلج شركات السياحه والسفر لاعاده الثقه
وجذب هؤلاء الزبائن في ظل هذه
الجائحه اعتقد ان نحتاج ان نقسم السوق الى
عناصر متعدده على سبيل المثال هناك الكثير
من الاوروبيين من اوروبا الشماليه
اسكندنافيا المانيا المملكه المتحده
وهولندا وايرلندا الذين يودون بان يتمتعوا
ربما بطقس مشمس في البحر الابيض المتوسط
اذا المؤشرات تشير ان هناك فعلا اقبال
ورغبه في مثل هذه الوجهات مثل اسبانيا
وايطاليا واليونان
لكن في الان ذاته هناك الكثير من
المجموعات التي لن تسافر في اي وقت قريب
لم نناقش حتى الان بالنسبه للرحلات
البحريه التي تعتبر مهمه بالنسبه لمناطق
مختلفه من العالم البحر الابيض المتوسط
ودول الخليج وجنوب شرق اسيا ودول الكاريبي
بشكل اساسي اذا قطاع الرحلات البحريه ربما
هو الذي ت بشكل اكبر مقارنه باي قطاع اخر
لانه يتطلب ان يكون
هناك موظفين وعمال من اكثر من 100 دوله
لانه مصمم لعدد من الوجهات وكما راينا
وللاسف
بسبب عدد السفن التي تاثرت بشكل كبير جدا
وواجهت مشاكل كثيره في بدايه الجائحه ربما
هذه الاماكن هذه السفن التي ربما قد تكون
فيها مستويات اصابه عاليه لذلك يكون هناك
تخوف كبير منها وعندما ننظر الى المساله
بشكل اعام نجد ان الكثير من
المسافرين من فئات عمريه متقدمه الذين
لديهم الامكانيات للقيام بذلك وهم يمثلون
جزء مهم جدا من قطاع السفر والسياحه سواء
تعلق الامر بالاشخاص الذين يسافرون الى
مصر من خلال ربما اقتناء السفن البحريه او
مثلا على نهر النيل او الذين يسافرون الى
البيرو او الى مناطق اخرى لزياره وجهات
مختلفه اذا كانت هذه الفئه لن لا تسافر
فان هذا سيفاقم هذه القطاعات بشكل خاص سيد
سايمن السفر والسياحه نحن لا نتحدث عن مجد
مجرد رفاهيه السفر قد يكون للعمل للدراسه
للعلاج فئات عديده حرمت من امكانيه التنقل
من منطقه الى اخرى ناهيك عن وجه اخر لهذه
الازمه قطاعات متعدده مرتبطه بالسفر
والسياحه خاصه ممن يعملون في هذا المجال
عشرات الملايين فقدوا وظائفهم وهناك
الملايين ايضا للاسف يتوقع ان يلتحقوا
بركب فاقدي هذه الوظائف وسؤالي للسيد
سايمن يعني ما التداعيات المرتقبه
لاستمرار هذه الازمه على مدى البعيد ان صح
التعبير على كل هذه القطاعات التي تحتاج
و يعني من هذا من هذين
القطاعين اذا نحن سنرى اثارا كبيره للغايه
وكانه شهدنا نزاعا دوليا كبيرا اذا الاثار
ستكون كبيره ومؤلمه والتي سنشهد ربما حتى
على المستوى
المتوسط ثلث اقتصادات السياحيه ربما قد
تندثر اذا ما اخذنا خطوط الطيران الكبرى
الاكثر نجاحا في العالم هذه الخطوط هي
تخطط الى خفض بالنسبه ثلث من حيث الحجم
وهذا يعني انه سيكون هناك عدد اقل من
المقاعد على خطوط الطيران
ليستقل الاسر والمسافر والرض وما الى ذلك
هذا بالاضافه الى مؤشره اخرى كلها كلها
توضح مدى جسامه الوضع الكثير من الاشخاص
الذين يعتمدون على سياحه قطاع الاعمال
سواء تعلق الامر بسائقي سيارات الاجره في
نيويورك او الفنادق مثلا في الدوحه او
ربما اشخاص الذين يقومون باداره مثلا
شركات ايجار السيارات او تاجير السيارات
في وانسب في جنوب افريقيا كلها كلها ستشهد
انخفاضا كبيرا من حيث الاعمال الموجوده
والتي ستجري اذا الاشخاص بسبب هذه
التداعيات سيحاولون ان يصرفوا اقل فاقل في
هذا المجال وسنشهد كذلك اجتماعات عن بعد
ولقد شهدنا تجربه مكثفه فيما يخص
الاجتماعات عن بوث في السته اشهر الماضيه
ربما لن تكون مجديه بنجاح الاجتماعات وجها
الى وجها الى وجه لكن ربما قد نرى ان
المدراء التنفيذيين الذين
ربما الذين كانوا يذهبون الى مقرات عملهم
الرئيسيه مره في الشهر ربما قد يحتاجون
الى زيارتها فقط مرتين في السنه الاثار
كذلك على قطاع التعليم كذلك ستتفاقم اذا
تدفقات الطلبه الصينيين او من اسيا الى
اوروبا والى والولايات المتحده كذلك
سيتراجع من حيث الاعداد نعم دكتور حسن
يعني تابعت معنا في الفيلم الذي سبق
نقاشنا حالات عن حرافيين عاملين يعني بصفه
مباشره او حتى غير مباشره بقطاعي السفر
والسياحه تبعنا قصصا من تونس من الاردن
وقس على ذلك في عده دول عربيه الملايين
ايضا اما فقدوا مصدر رزقهم ام او انه مهدد
او انه طالتهم خسائر كبيره في قوت يومهم
وبالتالي السؤال هل من تصورات ربما لحمايه
وتامين العاملين في هذا القطع خاصه وان
البعض منهم بدا يفكر حتى في تغيير مهنته
ان صح التعبير حتى يعني يمكن ان يوفر ان
صح التعبير ما يحتاجه اولاده
وعائلته اسمحي لي في البدايه ان ان نؤكد
ان ان فعلا كما تعقيب بسيط ان ان السياحه
ليست جسما منسجما بحيث انه هناك سياحات
وليس سياحه
واحده الازمه سيكون لها اثر كبيره على
نوعيه
وطبيعه الاعمال ما بعد ما بعد كوفي 19
فمثلا سياحه سياحه الاعمال اعتقد بان في
المستقبل لا اريد ان اقول بانها ستن
وانما الطريقه التي ستكون بها سياسه سياحه
الاعمال ستكون مختلفه بحيث انه يمكن ان
يكون بلاتوهات مثل بلاتوهات التلفاز
ويكونوا المتدخلين من جميع انحاء من جميع
انحاء العالم اما بالنسبه للاثار على على
المهن فعلا فان قطاع السياحه قطاع يجر معه
عده قطاعات وغالبا ما ما ننساها او
نتناساها فقطع قطاع الفندقه قطاع الاواء
قطاع النقل بجميع انواعه قطاع هناك
مقاولات صغيره في بعض الاحيان تكون صغيره
جدا هي مقاولات كراء السيارات مقاولات
كراء السيارات مثلا في في المغرب واعطيكم
ارقام لدينا
3940 شركه ايواء 1500 شركه النقل السياحي
1450 وكاله اسفار 1500 شركه كراء السيارات
اكثر من مليون منصب شغل اذا توقف هذا
القطاع ففعلا سيكون له اثار اجتماعيه
كبيره هناك من من من يحاول تغيير المهنه
ولكن هذا الامر ليس سهلا ك ومن حسن الحظ
انمت بها السلطات
المغربيه الحكومه ساعر على ذلك ان السلطات
ان السلطات المغربيه مثلا حينما قامت بخلق
صندوق كوفي 19 كان كانت
وحاليا حاليا لان الاثار ديال كوفيد كان
يقال بانه ستكون الى حدود 2023 2024
والمغرب قام ببدره كبيره هي بعد الخطاب
الملكي اشار انه ضروري
ضروره وجود خطه لانعاش الاقتصاد وانقاذ
الاقتصاد المغربي وفيها خطه القطاع
السياحي خطه 2000
2022 او عقد برنامج
الذي يعطي مجموعه من الصلاحيات
ومجموعه الايجابيات بالنسبه للمقاولات
التي تشتغل في هذا المجال ولكن شريطه ان
لا تقوم بتسريح العمال
و صندوق كوفي 19 كما يسمى ولاو فون
كوفيد سيمكن ايضا من اعطاء اجر للعمال
لهته لما تبقى من 2020 الذي يعادل تقريبا
2000 درهم بالنسبه لهؤلاء العمال يعني ان
هناك اجراءات التي يمكن ان نقوم بها من
اجل ليس لتطوير هذا القطاع وانما حينما
نكون في وقت صعب نبحث لا على تطوير ولا
على وانما على انقاذ المقاولات واعتقد بان
المسائل التي هي المسائل التي هي مستعجله
حاليا هي انقاذ المقاولات الصغرى
والمقاولات المتوسطه لان هي التي تكون هشه
وتكون وتكون ويكون موتها
سهلا سيد سايمون ما رايك في ما تفضل به
ضيفنا الكريم من المغرب دكتور حسن هل
الحلول تكون فعليا محليه ام انه
يجدر التفكير في حلول على مستوى اكبر كون
هذه الازمه عالميه وتمس الجميع في نهايه
الامر اذا لابد ان نقوم بلا الطريقتين
لابد لكل حكومه باقصى طريقه ممكنه لابد ان
تقوم بحمايه المجموعات التي تاثرت بشكل
اكبر لكن لابد ان ننظر الى تعاون دولي
افضل واكبر على سبيل المثال مثلا بعد خمسه
اسابيع ساسافر الى
مراكش المدينه
بالمغرب لاذهب هناك الى مؤتمر سياحي والذي
تم تنظيمه من قبل قطاع السياحه البريطاني
للاسف هذا تم الغاؤه لان هناك غياب لليقين
حول متى سيتمكن السياح بون السفر الى
المغرب سيد سايم يعني في عجاله لو تكرمت
اقل من دقيقه انت للاسف لن تتمكن من السفر
نحن لم نتمكن من السفر الملايين لم
يتمكنوا من ذلك والسؤال يعني ما المدى
الزمني المتوقع باعتقادك لعوده السفر
والسياحه خبراء تحدثوا ما بين ثلاث الى
خمس سنوات هل تعتقد
بذلك اعتقد ربما قد تكون المساله اقصر لكن
السفر لن يعود الى ما كان اليه في السابق
ما نتوقعه سيكون اضيق مما كانت الامور
عليه في الماضي لكنني امل اننا سنستمتع
بحريه السفر اكثر مما كنا نفعل في الماضي
اشكرك جزيل الشكر سايمن كالدر الخبير في
شؤون السفر كما اشكر جزيل الشكر الدكتور
حسن الزواوي الباحث في شؤون الاقتصاديه
ضيفنا الكريم من
الرباط ختام حلقتنا هذه نستودعكم الله
دمتم في رعايته وحفظه السلام
عليكم
h